in the seemingly quiet town of derry
which sits beside the penobscot river
that winds through central maine
historians have noticed a pattern of
horrible things happening every 27 years
one such historian and michael hanlon
hoped that the darkness would not
reawaken on schedule in 1984. so he was
most disappointed to learn of the fates
of adrian mellon in july of that year
mike hoped that the adrian melon
incident was an isolated one but it
would soon become clear that adrian had
been just the first victim of what had
become known as the dairy cycle a cycle
that mike had seen begin once before in
his lifetime with the untimely demise of
six-year-old george denbrough to learn
how adrian's case was linked to georgie
henry bowers and ultimately it
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to horror history there are
probably thousands of characters in
stephen king's 1986 novel
it so even with multiple long film
adaptations it's difficult to do them
all justice
in the case of melon that is adrian
mellon he didn't even make an appearance
in the 1990 miniseries it despite having
an entire chapter dedicated to him in
the book
he would show up for the 2019 movie it's
chapter 2.
the character was inspired by a real
victim named charlie howard he was
thrown over a bridge while walking with
his male partner after being harassed by
three teenagers about his sexuality
this took place in bangor maine which
the fictional town of dairy maine is
heavily based on the real life case and
the fictional case are almost exactly
alike in every detail except
for the end charlie howard ended up
drowning in the kendusky extreme but
adrian mellen would face a much
darker fate to understand his story i'm
going to take it all the way back to his
birth but before i do let me really
quickly tell you about this episode's
sponsor
ray khan as an owner of raycon earbuds
let me just say that everybody always
wants to try out and borrow my pair it's
easy to see why i mean today i was
listening to the song it is the end and
it sounds like you're in the studio with
the band
it's easy to see why musicians like
snoop dogg melissa etheridge and brandy
are obsessed with raycon
these everyday e25 earbuds are their
best offering with seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and great color
options which by the way i recommend you
go now because the popular color options
are really going fast you can also get
15
off if you use my link buy dot com slash
cz's world so go get your own damn pair
that's by raycon
dot com slash cz's world
[Music]
adrian mellon was born in october of
1951
like another it victim eddie kasparov he
had a bad case of asthma but
unlike eddie he wasn't always very
careful to protect himself from danger
and he would one day be described as one
of those fools who think things really
are going to turn out alright
the fact that adrian was only 5'5 135 in
adulthood didn't exactly make up for his
lack of protective coloration
adrian was like so many stephen king
characters a writer he graduated from
college in 1972 and went on to write
articles for all different types of
magazines and newspaper sunday
editions in his third year of college he
began work on a novel but only worked on
it on and off for the 12 years that
would follow a work ethic slower than
even nikki jakey
in 1984 he was on an assignment from new
england byways magazine to go to derry
and write a piece about the dairy canal
that was responsible for putting the
town on the map in the late 1800s
in the moose yeti movies dairy is known
as a beaver trap community rather than a
logging town
gary started as a beaver shopping camp
still is am i right boys so adrian asked
the magazine for three weeks of expense
money and he planned to gather
information on the dairy canal in five
days and just use the other two weeks to
gather material for four other regional
pieces
all while living it up in the dairy
townhouse hotel the same hotel that the
losers club would eventually lodge at
when they came back to battle pennywise
the following year it was during this
three week stay that he met don hagerty
don was living out the end of a
three-year lease that he had in derry
while commuting up the road to his
engineering firm in bangor
yes the town that derry is based on also
still exists in the world of stephen
king they're just two separate places
that are very similar by april of 1984
adrian and don were in a steady
relationship and would often go together
to drink at derry's gay bar the falcon
when adrian's stay at the hotel was up
he rented out a small apartment rather
than returning to portland and he ended
up living there just six weeks before
moving in with
don that summer would be the happiest of
their lives and for don
everything was great other than the fact
that his partner was really taking a
liking to the town of derry see he was
planning on moving out of derry once his
lease expired but adrian wanted them to
stay until october because the new
environment was inspiring him to be more
productive than ever on his novel and he
felt for the first time in 12 years that
he could finish it
so don took him to the kissing bridge an
area known as a lover's hideaway and
destination for graffiti and carvings
and he showed him examples of the
violently threatening
anti-gay markings and explains that he
doesn't feel comfortable in dairy
because there seem to be too many people
who have what he calls the deep down
crazies
hagerty does not fully realize it but
the reason that derry seems to be home
to so many deeply hateful people
is another phenomenon caused by it known
as the dairy disease in actuality it's
more of a curse than a disease but dairy
disease sounds better because of
alliteration ever since the creature
it's crashed in dairy millions of years
ago it's influenced certain inhabitants
to do truly
evil and horrible things the victims are
often social outcasts in the case of the
main characters the losers club each of
them has something about them that
causes the bullying
stand for his religion bill for his
stutter ben for his fat
miss eddie for his hypochondria richie
for his glasses
beverly for being the first to hit
puberty and mike for his race
sure bullying occurs in every town right
but the bullying on these seven at the
hands of henry bowers and his gang was
much more extreme to the point of being
life-threatening and the dairy disease
is what causes it to go
to this next level when adrian mellon
came to dairy the bullies that
threatened the losers club were gone and
locked away but it infected a new class
of bullies with those same psychopathic
tendencies
they were steve dubay christopher unwin
and john webby garton
who was the craziest and most evil of
the trio the henry bowers of the group
bowers had a disdain for all of the
losers but the one that he went after
the most was mike hanlon and this was
because bauer's father raised him with
an outlook of racism john garton
targeted adrian and don because he had a
prejudice of heterosexism
and in july of 1984 these two groups
would have their first
confrontation
[Music]
the dairy canal days festival was a
week-long summer event
made to honor the town's canal the
reason adrian came to derry in the first
place on the first day of the festival
on july 15th
adrian won a paper top hat that said i
heart dairy on it a reference to the era
of the town's inception
in the movie as i mentioned derry was
originally a beaver camp so the hats are
little beaver hats
i went to the canal days festival in
2019 as a promotion for it chapter two
so i can attest to how hard it is to win
adrian had eaten two fried doughboys
smeared in honey so he was feeling a
little bit of a sugar high at the
carnival as he and his boyfriend left
they were watched by unwin dube and
garton
who were disgusted at their display of
affection garton threatened to make him
eat the
hat and adrian perhaps due to his lack
of awareness about danger told him
he could find something much tastier
than the hat which infuriated garton
he's talking about his but before he
could react he was stopped by the police
officer frank machin
i can run you in my friend manchin said
and the way you're acting it might not
be such a bad idea
next time i see you i'm gonna hurt you
cartoon bellowed after the departing
pair and heads turns to stare at him and
if you're wearing that hat i'm gonna
kill you
this town don't need no like you they
don't run into each other again
until july 21st the final day of the
festival
many of the carnival rides at this point
are already being taken down so webby
unwin and dubai head over to the games
and webby tries to win the iheart dairy
hat but is unsuccessful in many attempts
i'm telling you it's harder than it
looks
so garton wants to let out his
frustration elsewhere and suggest they
go drive around
looking for trouble adrian and don come
out of the falcon bar after having a
couple beers each and walked past the
bus station onto the main street bridge
around
10 20 pm when they're spotted by steve
dubay and webby garton was especially
angry to see adrian wearing the i heart
dairy hats he's the first one to storm
up to them and demand the hats on this
night adrian was not gonna mess with
them and he was willing to hand over the
hat in exchange for them being left
alone but garton had no plans of letting
him off the hook that easily and socked
him in the face
if my assistant high school baseball
coach was there he would have
immediately got up off of one of those
buckets and yelled in the first
in actuality there were some people down
by the bus station right next to the
bridge but they did not respond to
hagerty's pleas for help another symptom
of the dairy disease
just like how ben eddie and beverly all
tried to call for help from adults when
they were being tortured by henry bowers
and his thugs and each was
left to fend for themselves when their
outcries were ignored don also tried
getting the attention of a passing car
but dubai pushed him to the ground while
the younger unwin kicked his stomach as
the crazy teens laughed and pushed
adrian around in a triangle punching and
ripping at him to draw blood as he
bounced around
don continued to call for help but the
only response came from
a small royce who repeated the word help
followed by a giggle and it happened
again causing him to peer down over the
bridge where he saw
a clown his initial thoughts upon seeing
pennywise was that it looked like a
cross between ronald mcdonald and bozo
which is perhaps a reference to the fact
that pennywise's first interaction with
georgie is inspired by one of the
earliest mcdonald's commercials
featuring ronald mcdonald
well hi isn't that mcdonald's hamburger
delicious
mom told me never to talk to strangers
well your mother's right as always but
i'm ronald mcdonald absolutely spine
chilling
pennywise offers don a balloon and tells
him they float
down here we all float pretty soon your
friend will float
too meanwhile unwind dubai and gartoner
chanting
bums rush over the edge a reference to
the term bums rush which is used in
canada and the northeastern united
states to refer to when someone is
thrown out of an establishment by the
seat of their past
we're getting kicked out apparently i
just wanted a picture
at 10 35 pm the three teams threw melon
off the side of the bridge down
23 feet into the canal before running
back to get in the car but before
retreating the youngest of the
perpetrators christopher unwin looked
over the edge and saw the clown
dragging adrian to the far bank of the
canal twisting its head and grinning at
him with his shining silver eyes and
great big
tea pennywise shoved one of adrian's
arms up over his head and took a huge
fleshy bite into his armpits hagerty
heard his lover's ribs splinter before
thousands of i heart dairy balloons
appeared out of nowhere and rose up to
hit the bottom of the overpass hagerty
would later describe the strings looking
like strands of white spiderweb a clue
about the monster's final form
don had a moment of understanding where
he believed that the clown he had seen
was a manifestation of the town derry
and in that moment
he ran the three boys would be sentenced
for their actions that night later that
year with garton receiving 10 to 20
years
duvet 15 years and unwin who had gone as
a juvenile six months but no clown was
ever mentioned at the trial
the situation with adrian mellon mirrors
what happens to the real life victim
charlie howard who was attacked while
walking down the street with his
boyfriend roy ogden in bangor maine he
was thrown into the same stream the
kendusky
and the ages of the aggressors 15 16 and
17 matched the ages of unwin
dube and garton respectively both the
real and fictional incidents took place
in july of 1984. but the incident
also mirrors what henry bowers and his
gang put michael hanlin through back in
the 50s
in fact when henry escaped the sewers
from pennywise in 1958 he washed up out
of a pipe
under the main street bridge the 57-58
cycle would end in the exact same spot
that the 8485 cycle would begin when
adrian mellon was taken by pennywise let
me know in the comments if there are any
other it characters you'd like to see
covered here on horror history and make
sure you check that playlist on the left
for everybody that i've already covered
so far remember to subscribe to cz's
world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we stay inside